el ataque de esta mañana a la base de al
azhar de la provincia de anbar no muy
lejos de siria hace parte de ese largo
enfrentamiento que hemos visto entre
esas milicias especialmente pro iraníes
y eeuu ellos piden que las tropas
norteamericanas en este país se retienen
y también hace parte de esa larga
disputa entre ira en eeuu especialmente
en un momento donde la atención es al
máximo por si eeuu regresa al acuerdo
nuclear pervivirán pide que se levanten
las sanciones económicas ya semanas
atrás habíamos visto otro ataque en una
base con presencia norteamericana en
erbil donde murió un contratista y hoy
vemos este segundo ataque este también
podría ser respuesta a ese ataque que
hicieron los norteamericanos como
respuesta al débil en la región de
adjudica mal dentro desidia donde habría
muerto al menos un miliciano pro iraní y
todo esto se da días antes de que llegue
al país el papá francisco en una
situación de seguridad que él ha dicho
la vuelta ha repetido hoy que vendrá al
país a mandar un mensaje de apoyo a los
iraquíes